what's the most insane risk you've ever
taken in your career moving to Los
Angeles was the most insane risk but I
ever took in my career I left Toronto I
had a TV series called boogies diner and
his garbage it was the shows were like
Saved by the Bell but nobody saw it so
that's awesome
it was a Canadian show in a Jimmy marsan
on it now James Marrs and you may know
him as Cyclops from the x-men but back
then he was just Jimmy
and it was crap like you should really
look it up how bad it was it was it was
horrendous though it was funny because
it was Canadian
it had to be shown on the Canadian
content channels so you have see FTO or
City TV in Toronto these are Canadian
channels and they they would have to
show a certain amount of Canadian
programming in order to qualify for
whatever they have to qualify for so
they put they put us there was cheers
great show and Seinfeld and in between
them was our piece of crap bookies diner
and if you look at sitting up you'd be
like oh it was bad it was horrible and I
would be able to borrow something that
people like turned me and go hey I saw
your show it's like oh really to go yeah
it's great you're working it's really
good you're working like no it's
I know exactly what it is but when that
finished I felt like I had hit a level
in Toronto that I was going to
constantly be that waiter walking into a
big movie saying you know uh salsa or
these tiny roles and just didn't matter
and I wanted to take a shot so I left
Toronto moved to kid Los Angeles stay
with my father lives up in
Pasadena and I I lived I went from
having a beautiful apartment down on the
lakeshore in Toronto to sleeping my
little brother's room on a pullout bed
underneath his bed and I would wake up
with gerbils and puppies peddling on me
which is awesome and the first couple of
jobs that I had I think the first one
was for the AF AF M no AFI American Film
Institute and it was his
I think it's called corner of gold if
you look it up I still have long hair
back then and like yeah and I shot this
thing I had almost no lines and you
gotta remember I had a series
that was my second series in Toronto I
had done this for years I made a living
doing it I made a lot of money doing it
not crazy money but me like a hundred
grand a year back that's like 25 that's
a lot of money dude had a nice car a
nice place I come out here I meet eating
ramen I'm starting over again and I do
this thing and I'll never forget this
this guy turns me after we finished
shooting this whole thing cuz that come
here I want talk to you like yo yo I
didn't have the glasses back then so the
eyes are much bigger and the hair is
long and just the goober and I'm like yo
what's going on he's like you know Zac
he was the sound guys like you knows
that gum I just want to say I was
watching you
you're really good really yeah you're
really good you're really talented
I think you're gonna go somewhere yeah I
have something for you
he reaches in his car d28 which in the
wallet takes out a card and in my mind
I'm thinking I've made my shot I knew
would work no one worked out for me she
just got a belief and he passes me at
cards like you called them you told my
giving me you told my giving the card in
my name like thank you so much shake is
in I don't even look at it yet I just
want to say thank you thank you so much
he turns around he walks away and I'm
like and it's an extras casting company
and I had never done extra work in my
life because I grew up doing it and it
kicked me in the balls so hard that I
realized that I had to start again where
no one gave a and I rode my
motorcycle home it was that motorcycles
from 1978 I had to wear a garbage bag
over my body taped around my arms
because I couldn't afford a rain suit
and I wrote back to Pasadena and I
thumbtacked that on the door and every
morning I got up I looked at it I just
was like you I'm gonna do better
every single day so it that was probably
the craziest thing you've ever done what
year was this 95 this is when you came
to Pasadena ya can okay came to
Hollywood came to Hollywood but state of
Pasadena yeah and did you ever call the
did you ever do actually you know so you
use that as like this fuel yeah yeah and
then once that whole conversation took
place how soon before you booked
something whether it was just a bit
partner cause a booked a movie about
three weeks after that for what's the
guy who did all them he did a little
shop of horrors
Roger Corman a Roger Corman was doing a
thing for Showtime back when Showtime
made crap and this was the Roger Corman
order our thingy
movie selections so we did this I did
this movie called star hunter which is
Stella Stevens Roddy McDowall and myself
and Rebecca budding and
ken Scott and it is it is horrible it's
horrible but it was awesome
I was shooting I was doing movie stuff
and I was up and running that's good and
you rode your motorcycle from Pasadena
like 4:00 a.m. to be on set yeah I do
you remember how you felt that first day
ecstatic ecstatic because that's
something that I was comfortable with
like I always I was comfortable I'm
comfortable being on set doing my job
helping people do their job being part
of the crew getting it done I've been a
PA an office PA a boom man and a grip
back in Toronto so I new set decorum
backwards and forwards and I grew up on
my mother's need be a backstage and
theaters or on film sets so once I hit
the set I'm ready to rock and roll
but trying to overcome the machinery of
all these people I don't know in
Hollywood the casting directors and how
to get there wasn't very very
intimidating when did you throw that
business card away still have it did you
take it down at some point from the door
yeah yeah but yes in a file guys don't
get it what's the file called I don't
know it's just in one of my filing
cabinets and it's you know you opened up
and ghosts come out
you